chamber is the most overpowered agent
valorent has ever seen
i'm a good shot
not your best
friend
i'm not taking it oh my god
from pro play to ranked chamber
terrorized every level of the game guys
broken take him out
shake him up the game and even when ryan
tried to nerf chamber they couldn't stop
him like if i was to make a change to
chamber that would be like the literal
last thing i do it's a [ __ ] sentinel
and we're taking away his alarm bye so
we had to ask did chamber ruin valorant
go
[Music]
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to ask you to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications if you
haven't done it yet it really helps and
once you've done that you can head over
to twitch.tv score esports and follow us
there so you never miss a stream alright
so back in november 2021 valerian
received a new agent chamber he was the
fourth sentinel added to the game but it
didn't take long for players to realize
that his kit didn't actually resemble
anything a sentinel did sentinels are
meant to play defensively gather intel
and anchor sights and chamber well aside
from his trademarks which do let him
cover flanks and lock down choke points
most of his kit is just guns chambers
headhunter ability is similar to a
sheriff in the sense that it does 55
damage to a body but with an ads feature
and no damage falloff it's basically a
pocket guardian and if that didn't make
chamber lethal enough his ultimate
ability toward a force is a free
operator that leaves a slow field on the
ground after every kill yeah chamber has
a free op his alt only has five shots
but with a similar ads speed and rate of
fire to the marshall this thing feels
busted a back up as well so he does go
re-explore he's going to catch the other
two in the slow field as well
no pressure felt on the back and there's
a freebie onto pancada we'll actually
re-swing it as well he finds another oh
closes things up confident swing through
from yay and the last but certainly not
least is chambers rendezvous ability you
place two teleport anchors and whilst on
the ground and in range of them you can
reactivate to quickly teleport between
each of the different anchors
with all of those abilities combined it
was pretty obvious right away that
chamber was strong
that's
wild brother last player's dancing
[Music]
10 seconds left
fight planted one enemy remaining
[Music]
oh
i love chamber man content creators and
casual fans were quick to lock in
chamber in matchmaking but it still
wasn't clear if he would cut it in pro
play after all while he was designed to
be a sentinel his kit put him in
competition with jett as a dedicated
opping duelist a role that she dominated
since the beginning of valorum's
competitive scene but no one anticipated
what happened next
as the 2022 vct season got underway a
few teams tested out chamber but jett
still dominated most regions with the op
once playoffs started though chambers
showed up a ton in one region in
particular and the dps is getting stolen
north american teams pick chamber in 51
of all playoff games 10 higher than
anywhere else in the world and when
optic went to reykjavik as one of na's
masters 1 representatives yay proved
that they just might have been slightly
ahead of the meta yay's not finding too
much with the tour de force in hand oh
as i say that
as well slip the net he's gonna isolate
one yay doing so nicely here trying to
clear up an s maybe a tag with a great
now for it
optics when in iceland happened in large
part thanks to yay's incredible
performance on chamber he proved that
the french agent could be a legitimate
replacement for jet but this raised a
few concerns because don't forget
chamber was supposed to be a sentinel
sure you could argue that he could be
played in place of a sentinel but most
of the people playing him were known for
their roles as a duelist jet players who
jumped shipped to chamber were
terrorizing everyone
oh
i'm not taking it oh my god and plenty
of pros were sick of it both using a
skeleton oh
no
that's just it's not that bad
of course people are gonna run into cryo
cells and let them ace i don't know look
at yay he's doing the same [ __ ] too yeah
no yes deagle is way better than his all
yeah but still i don't know i think the
up is broken shoots a little too fast
but truthfully one of the biggest
reasons why chamber replaced the other
sentinels in most team comps is because
the other sentinels kind kinda sucked so
in an effort to bring the other
sentinels back into the meta riot
announced that they'd be testing some
chamber nerfs on the pbe back in may the
proposed changes would remove one of his
trademarks and most people just couldn't
understand what riot was thinking
players expressed their concern almost
immediately if anything chambers
trademarks were the one part of his kit
that actually made him feel like a
sentinel they were the one thing that
was similar to a cipher trip or a
killjoy alarm bot so understandably
people were a little upset about this
nerf i think it's a little silly that
they removed
the only defining thing about a sentinel
from him from his kit if i was to make a
change to chamber that would be like the
literal last thing i do it's a sentinel
and we're taking away his alarm box
despite the backlash from the community
riot went ahead with the change but they
did provide a bit of extra insight as to
why they made the decision valerian's
comm strategist jeff landa said that
chamber's trademark outperformed other
sentinel tools in both reliability and
power which felt pretty unfair now riot
did add that they would keep an eye on
chamber to make sure he didn't suffer
disproportionately on defense when
compared to attack but if you can't
guess that never happened although
chamber couldn't entry as freely as jet
he was still the king of first
engagements whether on attack or defense
chamber players tended to rack up the
most first kills on the server according
to these graphs made by valor and
statistician will minder and the number
one reason why chamber can keep getting
away with this is his rendezvous ability
chamber could go for an opening pick up
someone tp out and by the time he got
back to the action there was a good
chance that the ability was back off
cooldown and chamber players could do
the exact same thing over and over again
the reason people always complain about
jet opers back in her heyday is because
she had a get out of jail free card jet
could get a kill and dash away without
much risk but chamber's rendezvous
ability was arguably even stronger than
jet's tailwind was then while jett just
needed two kills to reset her dash
chamber just needed to wait 20 seconds
he didn't even need to get kills to use
rendezvous chamber could just keep
taking free peaks without getting
punished now some of you might be
thinking sure chamber is a problem in
pro play but for the run-of-the-mill
player in rank he doesn't seem that
strong so what's the big deal well the
issue is that chambers pick rate and win
rates have actually surpassed jets
globally even without godlike aim an
average player can do some real damage
with chamber at basically any rank and
if you are a fan of pro valorant it's
pretty clear that chamber has made the
game less enjoyable to watch majority of
is just oh chambers sit here with up and
teepee away you know it's like that's
pretty much it and it's so strong but
it's so simple and one-dimensional that
it does make the game boring because you
don't see chamber updraft dashing into
anywhere after a flash no he's just he
might peek after a flash yeah but anyone
can do that he just tips away after how
like wow super innovative you can't deny
that chamber has indirectly ruined the
sentinel role as a whole since he can
fulfill the role of both a sentinel and
a duelist cipher killjoy and sage have
become niche picks only used by certain
teams on select maps they've been in
desperate need of some buffs for a long
time but if anything riot has only
nerfed kiljoy further by buffing ko's
fragment making her lockdown basically
useless the community continued to beg
riot to nerf chamber but nothing was
done most pro players accepted how
broken he was after all if you wanted to
win you had to play chamber winning
their jewels getting the reads all
pieces of that puzzle are just working
out like the biggest piece is
you might as well form an entire picture
with a puzzle piece of c ned you don't
need anybody else he completes a whole
team you gotta abuse the best agents i
guess and that's that's why every team's
doing and obviously most of the jet
players went past they're all playing
chamber now and they're shown you know
even though it's sentinel like it's got
the operator that's um and it kind of
like suits like the csgo playstyles at
masters copenhagen jet saw her lowest
pick rate ever at an international event
while chamber mains continue to dominate
the ulta's keeping him in position xiao
is going to make it very hard for him to
hear anything to expect those cues but
he's running
finding a new lease of life here as he's
just dominating the server between how
terrible it was to play against chamber
and ranked and how every pro team
basically had to run him players spent
months and months begging riot to put an
end to the agent's dominance and in
august their prayers were finally
answered riot nerf chamber by increasing
his cooldowns and raising the overall
cost of his kit and although it's hard
to say whether or not it's enough the
changes have been pretty well received
ultimate costs one more point that's
good bullet cost increased 150 that's
good on the whole i think that now
chamber clearly has you know downsides
there's clearly weaknesses to chamber
now uh that you know might make you want
to pick something else particularly on
certain maps still other sentinel agents
haven't been shown any love only time
will tell but even with the nerfs
chamber got it's hard to imagine a world
where his dominance will suddenly come
to an end maybe riot got it right but if
not chamber will continue to tear
valorant apart
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick talk